streets littered with crumbled facades
rescue teams in Ecuador scramble to save
those still trapped after the earthquake
on Friday afternoon
a part of a facade collapsed and fell on
a vehicle that had already been removed
by the police we had one victim without
vital signs a male person
a number of buildings have collapsed
across the coastal state of eloru and
uswai in the Andes
people ran out they yelled in despair
all the people got out of their cars I
don't know how an earthquake would feel
in a car but they were desperate they
ran they yelled they cried
there were reports of damage to
infrastructure across the region and
landslides blocking several roads the
trimmer was also felt across the border
in Northern Peru where a young child was
killed when her home collapsed
the baby was playing where the stain of
blood is she was playing with my other
niece and the brick fell on her
Ecuador and Peru are prone to
earthquakes they straddle the so-called
Ring of Fire and the danger isn't over
yet with aftershocks still ongoing Alex
beard Al Jazeera